hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
for Monday January 28th 2019 what's
going on
how's it going I'm doing this Sunday
night because I'm a busy freckled beaver
this week so I actually got a buddy over
gonna smoke a cigar with them I was like
well why don't we kill two birds with
one stone and I'll just have you on the
[ __ ] podcast the the one and only
Josh Adam ayahs hello everybody how I
can't do it why boys like how yeah I
know the voice of Holland Hank
DJ Hal and Hank is on a family we can
officially say that we're back we got
some funny [ __ ] for you this week season
for everybody season four you heard me
on the radio I have a feeling DJ Howlin
Hank will be making many many more
appearances I hope so I love that guy so
much it's not really hard for me to play
it we had coke addict DJ I mean that's
you know just think back into my past
don't worry I thought you were you oxy
pills what were I was I no I mean I mean
I got to did the whole smorgasbord lit
that way you're from I'm from Germantown
Maryland right outside of Washington DC
okay sports affiliations my podcast
listeners half thing here we go all crap
teams except for one of them Washington
Redskins Washington Wizards and the
Stanley Cup champion Washington Capitals
I can't believe I get to say that it's
like the greatest feeling in the world
and no Orioles no Nationals know I'm an
Orioles internationals fan of kind of
splits I mean I grew up an Orioles fan
but I loved Bryce Harper and I really
just root for the whole town so I'm a
die-hard Orioles fan but I'm also gonna
root for the Nats I just want that to
have been a Baltimore cult fan before
they left or no I was I was alive but I
was already Redskins I mean I mean they
left at what 80 to 84 something like
that something like that 83 84 somewhere
this is what sucks is that I remember
just my foot from like he's from like
zero to ten it was just three Super
Bowls and then at like 11 I think we got
our last one which was in ninth the
Redskins and then I was just like oh
we're probably gonna be in this all the
time and then nothing well that's what's
gonna happen to like the Patriots and
all these kids and who are lucky enough
to be born in the 1990s and remember
2000 the first one or two years in 2001
you know it's gonna be like you know
there was there was kids born when I was
born in 1968 and then they got to watch
Dan Marino I'm able just saying as far
as like just being good and competitive
I was compared to Dan Marino because
that guy was the best I ever saw me yeah
than Joe Montana but even then I think
Dan Marino with Bill walsh ysty
definitely wins one
I only remember I only remember bad
knees Marino that's that's where I was I
was that bad just bad everything when I
got in he was already in the in the down
trotty that was him he came in and he
was with Don Shula and Don Shula like it
was a man it was a man but but by then
everybody had caught up with them stolen
all his [ __ ] tricks and he was on
like his he was in the final ten years
of going back to like like the nineteen
like 50s I want to say he was on the
Giants at one point and he was offensive
a defensive coordinator and the other
guy was Tom Landry they're good those
were the two guys or something like that
won't know I always forget who the hell
was but anyways I just remember you know
we they went from Bob Griese to [ __ ]
Dan Marino's they just kicked our ass
for like the first 20 years of me
watching the patriot these couldn't take
it and I I look at the Dolphins fans now
like they're still waiting for their
next Dan Marino dude my cousin is the
biggest Dolphins fan he named his dog
Marino like he [ __ ] loves this team
so much and it was like I remember the
beginning of the season I was like dude
they're looking good
to winning some games and he's like
they're gonna [ __ ] it up and then boom
it's just what they finished like seven
and nine there are seven and nineteen
but I mean I can't talk the Redskins are
what like six and ten I gave up well I
know what's all four of our quarterbacks
broke a leg I was like all right I was
like we deserve it races team name we
can you can't be four and 12 with the
races team name you gotta be 12 and four
can't help it I will say this too I I
still can't believe and all of this this
[ __ ] hashtag and all this [ __ ] the
fact that they still do the Tomahawk
Chop
like I can't believe all of that [ __ ]
it's so [ __ ] bad it's so [ __ ] bad
they sit there like it does I love when
white people justify like it's literally
people are saying don't do yeah they're
like but we're honoring we committed
genocide who's getting rope against us
that would be like if the Germans won
and then at the soccer game everyone was
chanting oh hey oh you know what's funny
- is that whoa old-school Hollywood
imitating their singing and all that oh
yeah thing on so many [ __ ] levels
it's just like dude what can you just
and they just they [ __ ] refused and I
don't know that's why there's this like
a backlash now on white privilege like
there's people going out there and do
what just there's white people saying
that white privilege doesn't exist which
is [ __ ] any list of their stories and
all their stories are as basically that
they weren't born rich but at no point
hey I was driving down the street and
because I was white I got pulled over
tased and then shot to death yeah and
then the cop got free a cop was released
there's none of that
yeah like there's just like look there's
to sit there and act like there aren't
privileges there's privileges and
everything there's all different levels
to be in white and then this [ __ ] that
as if you're just like a regular white
guy [ __ ] that you see the private school
white kid doing
different levels of black people you
know there's a Huck's for sure I grew up
I grew up middle class some little note
lower middle class and it's just like I
had that friend that just like dude I
had a friend who was like super rich his
dad worked for the FDA right this kid
always had money that family always had
money his dad went into a Lonestar
remember that that steakhouse where they
put like he to give you peanuts and then
you just throw the shells on the floor
right huh his dad slipped on the floor
hurt his knee got like ten million
dollars they were already rich like
that's the kind of [ __ ] that should
happen to my dad because he having a my
dad I remember when being in New York
City one time and there was his
publicist who [ __ ] snapped or
something out on and she was out like I
want to say she was out in the Hamptons
Long Island and she or something
somewhere out there okay she snapped
because something about some club or a
restaurant and she backed into like 17
[ __ ] people and we left Rove away oh
that's horrible drove the [ __ ] away they
got a license plate they knew who where
she was and the cops showed up and the
lawyer was in the driveway met the cops
and said she'll turn herself in tomorrow
morning I remember reading that going
like what the [ __ ] how was that possible
is that what it's that yeah but so to
sit there and act like I don't know like
i-5 it's [ __ ] hilarious it is
hilarious
yes it's ridiculous everybody thing is
back with the Redskins working warehouse
and unloading drugs it's just like I
know but there's no point did anybody
ever look at you and like you have white
skin get out of this neighborhood yeah
just let him be that's the thing with
the Redskins though is that it's it's
every every like six years a senator or
a congressman says you've got to change
the name and I completely agree at this
point I'm like just change the name I
can't believe the owner wouldn't do it
considering I honestly don't notice now
because it's just been called that for
so [ __ ] right now but here look at
this to go look at the owner is first we
have other one of the worst owners in
football because he's like Jerry Jones
just that doesn't know anything about
football so he's [ __ ] the team up
he's causing all these problems you know
and and he wants money so bad
that you would think that he would
change the name to get all the
merchandising money like dude that's
like another you know hundred million
dollars worth of [ __ ] like if that pays
for a new you know party what I did
here's an argument that I've been I
believe something I've been wondering
about for a long for a while now
and I think I kind of understand it
we're in every sport they I like Major
League Baseball I thought they counted
World Series titles back to the 1880s
but they kind the first one that counted
in 1903 which I think was the Boston Red
Sox I literally looked it up last week I
already forget but like they can't
though all the way back to [ __ ] 1903
alright when it was a segregated League
all of this [ __ ] right like you know
crazy like Johnson it was [ __ ] ten
loved him ten teams or whatever right
Stanley Cup goes about that far back NBA
titles goes back to the 1940s and even
the Lakers count an NBL title they
somehow won and and and a title in the
NBL and that was counted as a [ __ ] NBA
title was that when they were the
Minneapolis Lakers yeah their first love
they want an NB L and then they won four
NBA titles in Minneapolis and but they
for some reason caught that one but
Super Bowls they only start in 1968 and
what kills me oh I saw you post up about
this yeah it's just like so so you're
telling me and people are saying because
it's I guess because they call it a
merger but it was like the AFL came in
it was like the XFL of the USFL or the
world football league it was just this
other competing football league and then
I felt laughs gon hear some [ __ ] you
know piece of [ __ ] League but it was
early enough on I guess well they you
know and they made enough moves and had
enough money or whatever and then with
the style that they played that they
started to compete with them and then
they played them in the first two games
Super Bowl 1 and 2 which were called NFL
AFL championship game and they got the
[ __ ] kicked out of him because they
weren't as good a league and then then
the AFL won in Super Bowl 3 which was
still not called a Super Bowl it was
still the afl-nfl championship alright
yeah so then after that
they agreed to merge all the owners
agreed in the AFL to merge with the NFL
Al Davis was the only one he wanted to
put the NFL out of business because he
was [ __ ] Al Davis he's white just like
yesterday I gotta love him right so and
then at that point they just go alright
so those first three games against the
afl-nfl that's when we're gonna start I
guess cuz they called it a merger rather
than but I mean like the ABA in a way
merged with the NBN yeah yeah and they
still count all that [ __ ] back to the
1940s they own the teams they only took
some teams from the ABA they didn't take
everybody okay but still oh yeah it was
it was a competing league that was
[ __ ] within numbers and they had a
more exciting game just like the AFL and
then in the end the NBA at you know was
losing too many players to it the same
way was the NFL at some point it's like
can't beat him join them and then they
came together but they still count all
those Celtics championships in the 60s
you know so it's like you telling me
that Johnny unites Johnny Unitas I got a
look at him in a certain way or in all
of the other half of those [ __ ] teams
the Browns the Rams the Bears the
Packers the Giants all of those [ __ ]
teams were in the NFL playing each other
there was it was actually in a way you
could say you know I can't say it was
more talent than but I'm just saying
like I don't get why they just wiped
that away they don't [ __ ] talk about
it at all and that the Steelers with six
[ __ ] [ __ ] in 2018 six championships
yeah
like it's so [ __ ] ridiculous that
that the Patriots right if we win Sunday
which would be next Sunday which would
be [ __ ] awesome we would be tied for
the most championships one in NFL
history and we've got our first one
[ __ ] 17 years ago that doesn't that
doesn't make send your ear that doesn't
make any [ __ ] sense that's stupid I
see where you're coming from but at the
same time you know we're going by
Superbowl one I think listen I'm not a
Patriots fan I think they have in the in
since they started winning them and what
2001 was that the first one yeah I mean
they're they're definitely in one season
so definitely
one of the strongest seen but all the
people that want to fight and put up the
fight about saying that you know well I
saw that thing that guy posted the Green
Bay has liked we've got like 14 or
whatever but he is Green Bay though
Green Bay's want for Super Bowls and
they won like [ __ ] 11 NFL titles
they've been winning the entire [ __ ]
time yeah but there's seven one in a
minute I mean how long has it been since
Green Bay's won when was that 2005
something like that I like 9 or 10 or
something okay you're right yeah but I'm
not talking about that with that well
then why would you [ __ ] count the
Broncos haven't won in 20 years so what
those there's don't count no no they
count they I'm saying they count but I
just thought you were getting mad about
somebody posting that Green Bay had X
amount because they were in close
earlier well that's my argument they
should keep those yeah but those should
[ __ ] count if the [ __ ] Montreal
Canadiens can count when they [ __ ]
beat somebody playing on a pond oh I
didn't know what you angle you were
going with I thought you were going
against I thought you were saying no
those people for it okay then I love the
history of the game the NFL has been the
NFL and a bunch of [ __ ] leagues have
tried to to compete with them they've
never they've never been able to the
best you ever had was the AFL merged
with them but it was still called the
NFL it wasn't called the AFL it wasn't
called the NFL slash AFL like Sirius XM
or whatever right yeah it was called the
[ __ ] NFL you joined the NFL yeah so
those other Championships where NFL
championship that's cuz now you called
the [ __ ] Super Bowl sure it was still
the two best teams and those you know
before the AFL existed
those were the two [ __ ] best teams
out that [ __ ] classic Giants Colts
game played and [ __ ] Yankee Stadium
the winner of that it can't can't
[ __ ] walk up to somebody once Super
Bowl four and said I know what that
feels like they know exactly what it
feels there a lot of people are dying
off but yeah they know what it feels
like 100% that's a great point they are
dying I don't know I I count them all
right the Green Bay Packers are the
[ __ ] New York Yankees and I think the
Giants are next and that's the way it
should be
did I think it was well the Redskins are
up there the Redskins have
we have no you got you a three and then
we had I think we had like for the World
Championship ones - all right I'm gonna
give you some trivia where did the ramps
first start it I'm in the city st. Louis
no no what can I do is with Los Angeles
I don't [ __ ] know you just sounded
like me in math class a long time ago I
know I know sports but dude you know
[ __ ] sports like you like I can
imagine I know a fair point because I
used I used to know [ __ ] everybody in
the league and I just don't have time
anymore so I I don't know but they
started off in Cleveland and I've never
understood why they would call the Rams
I don't know that there was any Rams in
there all right let's let's look up what
am I looking to Washington [ __ ]
what's your fight song hey Briggs I know
what bad fight for Oh DC oh hey guy that
it goes into so weird thing Brandon
doesn't jump in there's an oddball Steve
Adama dooble at the points alright here
we go
NFL championships pre 1970 merger you
got - alright five pretty good I'll take
it
yeah so you got five so right now it's
for the way I look at you tied with the
Patriots we got five Super Bowls you got
you got five champion we got we have
five championships I wish everybody
thought like you because a lot of you
know there's a lot of people you [ __ ]
people have ever said that agree with
what you're saying if the one before it
was the official Super Bowl it's still a
championship unfortunately a lot of
those people have died yeah who would
care I guess let's see yeah yeah
that Peppa Peppa Peppa all right
League championships all right the NFL
champion T the Giants won four so
they've won for NFL titles and they won
four Super Bowl types what doesn't you
go to the stadiums they're nowhere to be
found
they no they're not listed it's like it
never [ __ ] happened I don't see the
angle you're coming with right now and I
respect the what you're saying dude a
hundred percent that's not fair I'm not
saying it's not fair I'm just asking why
why was your mother - dude league
championships Chicago Bears okay they
won [ __ ] nine 1921 1932 33 40 41 43
46 1963 and then they won a Super Bowl
1985 and all they have is one [ __ ]
banner hanging over their stadium check
one of the scores when they beat the
Redskins in one of those league
championships it's like it's like crazy
[ __ ] lob 17 like 72 8 I'm not
mistaken sports about facts but I do
know that I think that that is right all
right let's look up the Los Angeles Rams
all right and you find ervice are you
nervous about Sunday oh yeah always I'll
tell you what's the funniest thing my
virzi texted me and he's like dude Todd
Gurley is it Todd Gurley Todd Gurley
yeah he goes he's hurt and in my head
I'm like dude there's no way to stand up
comedians know the injury status of the
key running back for the Rams if I got a
guy on the inside
yeah who's your guy on the inside IES PN
com this is Mike if he was really
[ __ ] hurt we wouldn't know they would
keep that under wraps but he was hurt in
the last game I saw them on the bike for
a little bit I know but here's the thing
but he's everybody's hurt this time of
year at they all said he's got to fight
for cover
he's gonna [ __ ] play if they're
leaking it out that he's hurt that means
he sees way better than they thought he
was gonna be because that that's just
good always hurt and that but they know
Belichick is gonna be like well I guess
we don't have to prepare for Todd Gurley
but it's just funny oh no he showed up
yeah all right NFL championships
pre-1970 the Rams they won in 45 and 51
and then they won in 1999 and they were
thee yo Cleveland Rams from 1936 to 1942
they took 43 off to finish off the
Germans in the Japanese 1944-1945 that
was the last year and then they moved to
Los Angeles they stayed there till 94
came back to 2016 which brings me to
something I was making fun I'm gonna let
did you see do you watch the Saints Rams
game I did all right everybody thought
the worst [ __ ] thing in that was that
[ __ ] helmet to helmet no past
interference call the worst thing in
that game was when they cut to the
stands after the Rams won and you saw
those guys in the Rams jerseys in their
20s maybe early 30s crying I saw that
yes I didn't see that girlfriends were
trying to comfort them it's just like
buddy you were [ __ ] 2 years old when
they moved away like what are you doing
here you've been waiting since 2016 Ryan
went bill when you because you remember
how what happened when we watched cuz
you watched the caps game with me when
they won the Cup you were on my computer
I was in London or in London but I was
facetiming you so you could watch the
game if you everybody was asleep and I
was pitch black and I was in the
bathroom of my hotel my wife and
daughter were sound asleep and I was
going do it I'm so happy for you just
like I did time with you and you you had
your [ __ ] TV I know it but I probably
thought I was in there talking to a
hooker beautiful it's so beautiful but
what was what was so funny is if you
would have seen me and I mean like I
remember in 91 with the Redskins won but
I remember the day after because my mom
like I was watching the game and then
the
my mom made a bunch of her famous Super
Bowl chili and I ate a bunch of it and
then I fell asleep in a laundry basket I
was 11 and then I didn't get another
championship so this caps won and we
were watching it together and you were
facing the screen and I remember I was
just like cheering as the clock ran down
and then the remembered stop for a
second there was like a stoppage of play
at like point zero six seconds so I was
screaming and then I got quiet and then
they win the game and everybody's
running on the ice and I'm just dead
silent I thought I was like am i dead
inside what is wrong with me and then
they brought the cup out and dude I just
started weeping just weeping dude does
it matter so much it's so sue it's guy
it's everything it's just all the it's
it's all dude it's everything it's all
the it's all the it's all the you know
the times that they they they chunked it
before when they were supposed to win
and all the times that you know they did
she put so much into it and to finally
get it just was so sweet man and it was
like I started thinking about like this
is gonna go really like John Cougar
Mellencamp here but like I thought about
all like the middle-class people that
live in the Washington DC area that work
these dead-end jobs and then they just
they get that championship because they
want it so bad and that that team
whether it's the Redskins and the Cavs
or whoever it's like that's what they
have Tim tell them escape and so I you
know I went for bringing seeing your
team raised the cup is just like I I I
kind of was just like I don't think I'm
ever gonna see the Bruins do it and when
they finally did it
I watched him from 1980 to 2011 that's
how long it took me to us at ten twenty
thirty one year 31 I watched him and so
from age 12 - what is that 43 when they
finally they finally did it and I was I
told the story before I was at the
Chicago theater on Jim Norton store with
Jim Breuer David telling myself on this
tour called the antisocial tour and I
watched the first period and a half then
I went on stage and then when I
offstage I watched the final seven
minutes upstairs in one of those or the
green room is something like that and I
remember being up there by myself
because none of them cared because it
wasn't that team and the show end and
they went out to do the meet-and-greet
and I stayed up there and there was like
three minutes left and they scored a
goal or it's just not enough time for
the other team to come back from Coover
and I was by myself and my I went up
like nine octaves I was like and I and
all I wanted to see they were like wait
come on you got to come down for the
meeting great people saying where the
[ __ ] are you calling you the bony for
naught I was like way nice I just had to
see him lift it up I told my wife to
tape but I knew she was taping it and
just when I saw Cedeno just lifted I'm
just going yeah dude that was 31 years
just coming out of here just uh all
those years of not being able to be get
past the canes not being able to win in
the forum yeah man [ __ ] getting past
the Canadiens and then run into those
[ __ ] Gretzky Edmonton Oilers and the
Mark Messier Edmonton Oilers and just
and then just you know
Neely's getting this [ __ ] leg taken
out you know and bore kevin to go
somewhere else to win a cop and it's
just [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] the
lockout oh yeah just goes through your
head and then BAM I think you literally
feel like they're good there's gonna
like look at looking like at your
television screen and go or do you want
to hold it up and you could just like
grab it it's just such an incredible
feeling I have such respect for that
trophy I would never touch it I won't
even touch it so why because I'm not it
because you should be the you should be
on a team that [ __ ] one players who
play in the league won't even touch
unless they want it so me some [ __ ]
[ __ ] because who's gonna let you lift
it up dude they might let you get like a
bomb on it but that's about it I respect
that I've seen pictures of guys I know
that know players and [ __ ] and they're
like holding it with them like what the
[ __ ] you doing with your hands on that
but no I respect that I respect that you
you
in fact it back sit back with the Green
Beret that saw action you got your face
all painted too like you did something
you're paintballing quick with your
paintball gun I watched you on CNN
anyways I got a little bit of
advertising here I have to read hit me
let me see here what do you get with a
[ __ ] this this always happens
Joanna Meyers why does this always
happen okay Oh 1-800 flowers Valentine's
Day is coming up there buddy wait by now
most of us have started racking our
brains about what Valentine's gift is
truly gonna make her Day special dude
[ __ ] that it's any woman out there
[ __ ] racking their brains about what
kind of [ __ ] stupid thing they're
gonna get you know you know a guy should
do we should get into some what [ __ ]
thing could you pressure them we'd be
funny like ladies you know Valentine's
Day what kind of flatscreen is thinking
about some Sonos audio well that's shiny
[ __ ] with 1-800 flowers dot-com it's
really not that complicated roses from
1-800 flowers are a no-brainer right now
when you order early 1-800 flowers says
amazing deals on vibrant and romantic
Valentine's rose bouquets is it bouquet
a bouquet who says bouquet
it's bouquet bouquet okay okay I'm gonna
get a bouquet okay
tomato tomato it's something that
arrangements and more starting at $29.99
this is a great thing to do though to
[ __ ] get this done oh yeah to order
ahead of time to get this [ __ ] thing
done and then you then you just then you
just find some other stupid [ __ ]
thing that you can do you send the
flowers to work so everybody she can
feeling ink again for of all the [ __ ]
friends you know that's what it's all
about
oh yeah so you don't send it to the
house you gotta send it to a public ABC
people to see that stupid woman that's
what they want see my pussy's better
than yours there are so many
unbelievable teas from 1-800 flowers but
you have to hurry
roses roses are red roses from 1-800
flowers are picked at their peak and
shipped overnight to ensure freshness
amazing just pictured the miserable
bastard picking those things gorgeous
does he have any love in his life
balance
gorgeous Valentine's bouquets an
arrangement starting at $29.99 is an
amazing deal but it won't last long
bouquets prices will be going up soon so
take advantage today pick your delivery
date and let 1-800 flowers handle the
rest when it comes to Valentines I don't
settle for anything less than my Rose
Authority I guess I supposed to be
talking 1-800 flowers come to order
Valentine's bouquets arrangements and
more starting at twenty nine and nine go
to 1-800 flowers calm click on the radio
icon and enter birbee you are order
today and save at 1-800 flowers calm
cold bird I love how you slowly turned
into Waylon Jennings towards the end of
that I just get an and and man I have to
do anything I can because I can't read
out loud anything to keep an entertainer
I love the the bouquets that's fantastic
hello that's like I tell me that's my
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude alright hymns you know
I'm saying it wasn't us it was them
that's why I got hymns from that's from
other warriors was I've never seen the
Warriors em you never seen the war never
seen the Warriors I started and then I
fell asleep I'd like two months ago I'll
get into it one day okay hymns why do
guys turn to weird solutions or do
nothing when they can turn to medicine
and science what are they talking about
solution for hims calm I once stopped
for hair loss skin care sexual wellness
oh god what the [ __ ] was that oh I
turned it on to make sure I knew you
were coming oh [ __ ] I forgot to send
that [ __ ] lady a check all right what
am I doing here for hims a one-stop shop
for hair loss hair loss skin care sexual
wellness for men this is the whole thing
dude you're gonna clear up your skin you
a bag and you could have a [ __ ]
[ __ ] motivate your audience talk
about your experience with the product
well you know I'm talking about that I'm
married I'm [ __ ] bald your skin looks
great yeah that's right choose one or
two coffee points to rotate into your
spot why they tell me thanks to science
baldness can be optional well [ __ ]
thanks for telling me
hims connect with your with connects you
with real doctors and met a good good
real doctors this time and medical grade
solutions to treat hair loss well known
generic equivalents to name-brand
prescriptions to help you keep your hair
no snake oil pills or gas station
counter supplements prescription
solutions backed by science I like that
snake oil and gas station solution they
said that was from like the 1930s they
still do that they go to any like any
like you know gas station and you can
get those like you know black mambas are
like just just like dick bells whatever
dude they sell them all by the counter
yeah dick pill that's a good name for a
band no waiting room no awkward
in-person doctor visits save hours by
going to for hims fo r hims calm so easy
answer a few quick questions doctors
will review and can just prescribe you
products are shipped direct to your door
all right
order now my listeners get a trial of
four hymns for just five dollars today
right now while supplies last
see website for full details this would
cost hundreds if you went to the doctor
or a pharmacy go to four hymns calm
slash bird that's fo r hims calm slash
bar for hymns calm slash / and lastly
but certainly not least Lee
stamps.com postage rates have gone up
again can you believe how many cents it
costs to send a [ __ ] envelope from
here to [ __ ] New York thankfully
stamps calm can ease the pain with big
discounts off post office retail rates
stamps calm makes it easy they'll send
you a free digital scale automatically
calculates exact postage stamp sucker
will help you decide the best class
male based on your needs they'll even
give you postage discounts you can't get
at the post office including five cents
off every class class stamp I use stamps
comm to send out all my posters I'm a
[ __ ] if I can figure it out so can you
right now my slash our listeners my
listeners get a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus free
postage and a digital scale see for
yourself why over 700 thousand small
businesses use stamps calm just go to
stamps calm click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in
Barbie URR that stamps.com better bar
alrighty hey you have a podcast I do you
do miss funny I was watching you read
that and like you just keep going when
you make the mistake and like when I try
to tape stuff like that if I like if I
[ __ ] up at all I just like I'm like I
goddamn and I just like to have a start
over it's a singing so effortlessly yeah
a reflection Asst we were so comfortable
doing it well I you do I've right out of
the gate that I'm a [ __ ] yeah I got out
in front of it yeah
Bill Clinton saw what happened and Gary
Hart he just got out in front of it they
were just like did you is like I [ __ ]
them all and then he [ __ ] you know
yeah but then he went back to his old
ways I did not have sex with that woman
that's a good Clinton dude and I if I
said if I went I I do not have problems
reading out loud like that would be the
end I would get impeached sure I'd be
you know I wouldn't leave just like him
I need to leave my flaws in that's what
it taught me to do yeah I do have a
podcast I love it bill I'm telling you I
love this 500 the 500 it's about stock
car race it is not about that
it is about the 500 greatest albums of
all time I'm going through Rolling Stone
magazine's list of the 500 greatest
albums starting at 500 working my way
down to one each week I sit down with
comic actor or musician now you know and
I give them a week with the record and
then I break the record down and we sit
down to talk about it it's kiss
we did I just did I just did with Jeff
Ross kiss destroyer I was gonna say you
know you could have got Steven Adler I
mean I've got love I would love to get
Steven dude I love this so much man like
because it's not just being able to sit
down and talk with my buddies about the
album and ask them questions
around like the meanings of the songs
and the facts from the record but dude
since I've started doing this like I
have listened to music that I thought I
would never listen to didn't even know
about and it's like touching me and it's
just so incredible right now I'm
listening to Steve Earle
guitar town you ever heard of him this
guy is but he's like he's like the this
is like his born in the USA but country
record dude I never listened to country
I [ __ ] love this record dude when did
it come off 1985 and he has a song
called guitar town and it's it's just
it's just incredible I mean what
especially once you know the history of
this guy and like how he dropped out of
school and then went to Nashville like
you know to find Townes Van Zandt and
like was writing songs for people and
then the record company was like all
right what we want you to make a record
and he was like alright and he just sat
down and wrote the first song and the
last song and then just the whole album
came together but it's like that's what
I loved how many ARMs does he have oh
he's got a shitload Oh does he listen to
anything else so he must be real quality
because I don't know who he is you know
I mean I figured like if I know who a
country person is for the most part they
suck because it's gonna be like you just
know like the pop kind of here's the
thing though you don't know it's like
you know like if you were I don't know
if somebody say a name is speed
Battlement metal band everybody would
know say motorcycle you would say motor
motor sick of our favorite band no this
is this is the thing the guy could have
been like enormous but then he developed
like a drug problem and then kind of
fell off and now he actually still makes
music but country the country fanbase
doesn't really [ __ ] with him anymore
because he leans very left and I was
actually watching a documentary of
because I'm getting ready to record the
episode with Tom Everett Scott from that
thing you do he played the drummer you
remember when he came and did it at the
jam and you look at the YouTube comments
you know of this documentary and it's
like I used to like his music but he's a
[ __ ] stupid leftist Libertad and it's
just like because they can't accept that
you know you can play country music but
still lean toward it's also why I think
you know you shouldn't be constantly
putting out your political opinions like
listen I just completed completely fun
of people you know the white privilege
thing I like this I make fun of
feminists and [ __ ] I try to be like
even-handed or whatever but you know all
you do is just like nobody all you do is
get people who agree with you to agree
with you and then people who don't agree
with you to now hate you and not want to
watch something that you do because they
can't separate the two like I can stay
at a [ __ ] Trump hotel and not like
Donald Trump and a lot of people can't
get past that because in their minds the
people who run the Sheridan who were
also billionaires for some reason didn't
vote for Donald Trump yeah they're all
the same [ __ ] 100% yeah but not to
mention like it's just they just paint
for his name outside the thing it's not
likely and it's I've been in a Trump
Hotel they're extremely nice they're
incredible they're incredible yeah I
said nice I mean everybody knew what I
might even have to one-up me and say
incredible it was incredible I've only
stayed at one it was [ __ ] it's
fantastic like does that one up
incredible what this guy should be doing
[ __ ] yeah dude if it's just stick to
hotels be on residency was he commenting
as his [ __ ] hotel I mean this this we
would be back he would make it great
again if its tax cuts were as good
his bath towels I made god the fact you
know the other day somebody said well
like there was something I guess there
was some sort of taxing out there if you
make 11 million dollars or more and
people make 11 million dollars or more
we're complaining all right so somebody
had tweeted that you know hey you know
this is [ __ ] [ __ ] just pay your
fair share someone makes 11 million
dollars a year doesn't work any harder
than somebody makes 20 grand a year and
I was [ __ ] dying laughing it's like
oh yeah they do
yeah they do yeah they do you wonder why
a guy making 11 million dollars is
getting a [ __ ] divorce it's cuz he
never sees his wife
that's why sure yeah right doesn't see
his kids has a pool never been in it and
it's just like yeah this is 24 [ __ ] 7
I I've made 20 grand a year
yo it's great it's the second the
[ __ ] whistle blows you don't even
think about that job what's what I think
nobody calls you up hey Bill tomorrow
when you unload the boxes could you baby
do it we need to get have a [ __ ]
conference call at how you unload the
[ __ ] truck it's just as people don't
think that people think of like when you
think somebody makes 20 million a year
like we just know [ __ ] from like Falcon
Crest and dynasty all those shows like
they don't do anything hang out of
country clubs and they piss on us twenty
thousand or yeah and you have pay petty
fights with people within your family
yeah that's all they do
like nobody sees them like you know in
the office from you know from 6:00 a.m.
until like 3:00 a.m. and then they go
home like walk into their kids room the
kids sleeping they shut tingled tear
drop falls and then they go bang the
mate and go to sleep yeah it's kind of
why that's what I assume happens I have
no idea
I grew up lower middle class but I love
I what I love about this podcast is that
I would do this if nobody was listening
because I wanted to listen to to these
albums and I started to I was just gonna
I wanted to feel inspired I think I was
just musically tapped out and and I was
like all right I'm gonna listen to an
album a day over 500 days and I started
posting about it and when I got to like
498 which was like on the third day Jim
Jeffries reached out to me he's like
dude he's like that Stone Roses record
is one of my favorite records he's like
all the stories that I think
when I hear that music and then it like
hit me and I was like that's the podcast
I've been waiting to do it's a great
voice suck he can sing
wow he's the incredible voice but he
came on and he did and he did that
episode and that's basically what it is
it's like you know we're gonna go
through these great records and we're
gonna talk about him we're gonna I'm
gonna I'm gonna ask you need more than a
day to listen to an album that no I give
him a week he just pointed it at me no
oh we I give you a week oh yeah well you
did it you did but you only took a day
to listen to it because you're so busy
because you're making 12 million dollars
so you're out I'm have a million and one
dollars 11 billion to one so I was the
one who complained I can tell it was you
that was so but what it is is like I
give every comic or actor whoever it's
gonna be a week with the record and then
I break the album down and like ask them
questions about their life using the
meaning of the songs the facts from the
record so so the album is really just
like the celery and the carrots and the
onions of the soup but it's really just
you know the basis for me just to have a
really you know funny or deep or
whatever the [ __ ] it is it's just a good
conversation when you run out of those
albums it's over there no I know how you
do it next you do the 500 albums that
should have been in the top 500 that'll
be in nine point six one years and
that's not a bad idea but I might just
be you know I think I'm gonna retire it
on May 31st 2028 oh that's what we're
gonna have my goal is on the final
episode to have Oprah I don't know why
but it's just it's my white whale what's
the number one sergeant pepper's Lonely
Hearts Club Band then it's then it goes
the number one Elvis number one and then
number two is Pet Sounds and then number
three I think is revolver this is White
Rock the number one White Rock in the
top ten no Marvin Gaye's in the top ten
Marvin Gaye is number six
Marvin Gaye what's going on but it's
it's all over the place the like album
500 was outcasted quim and I and then
for Hobby sales because the Beatles who
really went rogue and started their own
Beatles were essentially a boyband and
then they that is that they took control
there's a lot of people because the
Beatles now get a ton of [ __ ] by people
being like you know I don't like they
there's like people who think they stink
like I've listened to two things the
Beatles stink dumb people well they're
they're dumb yeah I'm not saying you
can't be into them they don't movie or
whatever I'm it's been a long time but
that that's that's like saying Count
Basie Stakes or something like snow it's
just so yeah you don't
that's the thing is that somebody like
my age I'm 39 like I I you know was born
in 79 so I wasn't really alive during
the Beatles era and from what I've been
told and everything I've read like there
will never be an artist as big as the
Beatles were like they were enormous
like what was they broke out of what
usually binds you and they took control
their career and started their own label
and then when they should have fizzled
out they made this left turn where they
reinvented themselves you know when they
started doing drugs and grew their hair
and all that [ __ ] Rubber Soul and then
yeah and revolver and all that stuff and
then when that kind of went - they were
now what the [ __ ] do we do was like
alright let's just play characters now
we'll be these these guys how would
these guys do that you know during that
time Marvin Gaye I think he was stuck in
the Motown [ __ ] and he's got to sing but
they're writing for him and by the 70s
you know he was doing what they did as
far as he kind of broke ways like well I
want to sing about what I'm thinking
about rather than when my version of she
loves you yeah yeah yeah well he's doing
like heard it through the grapevine and
all that stuff which I still love all
those songs everything but then he
wanted to go like deeper so maybe they
think that that's because well Sergeant
Pepper
I was acting what's going on is a better
record than than Sergeant Pepper yeah I
mean it's listen they all of these all
of this whole list is completely you
know yeah it's just it's all over the
sign to do these you got like because of
the way they made it because I've
already had this discussion with people
is like 20 years ago today Sergeant
Pepper drop the band to play ski ski
badoo badoo yeah something like one of
the best moments we've had on the gym is
when Jim Jefferies sang that first time
he did it he did Sergeant Pepper and
then into with a little help from my
friends and he was wearing a jacket that
he bought at John Varvatos that the only
reason he bought it's the gaudiest like
most expensive weirdest jacket you ever
seen in your life and it costs like
$10,000 and he only bought it because he
was at this John Varvatos like event and
he put it on to laugh about it and then
Ringo Starr walked by and when you look
good in that so he was like well I gotta
buy it now I mean if a Beatle tells he
look good in something it's like he got
all you know get the [ __ ] when I go
Star Wars they're gonna do Ringo's
always add like Varvatos events he wears
all that like interview with all the
Empire hello then yeah a vente yes it
wasn't a store not it didn't no no I
spaced halfway through this okay oh it's
great it's great so what I'm saying is
is that you know Sergeant Pepper
was this huge thing for the Beatles
because what was the coat what did it
have one oh my god it was like an
alligator gold style like like rock
Jackie I don't even know what you'd call
it just like a piece of that if he buys
it was it a Beatles coat no he was
seriously saying he looked good in that
[ __ ] coat he was just saying to John
he was ain't a gem that you look good in
it and so he told him you know he's like
he looked good so Jim bought it that's
the story areas he was boring the second
time it was interesting the Frey he's
based out he's laughing that you know
I'm not [ __ ] listening from but we're
not paying attention or whatever you
didn't think that when I sang
Johnny paycheck take this job
doctor I believe madaba debo oh do what
josh has been trying to get me to do
you're gonna do it um he wants
[ __ ] you are gonna do it it
wants me to get a brown curly wig go out
on stage is Don Henley and then he wants
me to play drums and sing Hotel
California I'm gonna help you I'm gonna
help you in the crowds gonna help you so
everybody noticed his bills talked about
it I do a show called the goddamn Comedy
Jam where comedians do stand-up they
tell a story about a song and then they
sing it bill has done it you've done it
more than [ __ ] like anybody or the
counts it cuz it was pre the NFL AFL
merger they don't call back
i but but we had my birthday coming up
and and I asked you I was like could you
please do that and I was like I'm gonna
do it and then you called me and you
give me one of your I've gotten this
call a few times where it's like Josh
dude I got too much [ __ ] going on I
can't learn this [ __ ] song don't play
the song but the fact that I have to
sing along with it and I can't sing but
you understand that's the song that's so
popular the second you start playing it
the whole audience is gonna [ __ ] join
in with you and then you can just kind
of mimic it and and then I'll be singing
and the bass player will be singing the
Queen like all the [ __ ] lyrics in
front of me like it's it's gonna be a
[ __ ] show thing I can do I think you
know I can make that happen we listen
there's one in March I got one coming up
March 20th we haven't done one in a
while yeah like my schedule doesn't open
up again and so [ __ ] April like I'm
just strapped straight I don't want the
[ __ ] a padieu I got in this business to
not working now but we're doing we're
doing efforts for family man I gotta be
kinda way dude right and [ __ ] we're
already up to Episode three
we're cruising that's great yeah but
cruising but I mean yeah it takes a lot
a lot of time alright let's get it to
some point I will say Hotel California
I wanna do that one part where is the
timbale alright body-shaming we got
people right in and then they for some
reason they wanted voice I know this
goes down alright body shaming yo Billy
brown shirt I don't know what brown
shirt the people is sympathetic to
[ __ ] Hitler I have no idea what brown
shirts my brown shirts uh wait a minute
I got looked at now you got it something
political maybe they just saw you in a
picture that you posted in a brown shirt
and they are they're just rhyming it
sure dude they said so many weird things
like Billy elbows are billy dingle dong
yeah so they just made it up
no brown shirts political
Nazi parties original parliamentary it
plays a significant role in Adolf
Hitler's rise to power
no I guess all you do is brown shirts
see that's what the Internet's stupid
cuz I just I just [ __ ] grazed overall
it graze breezed grazed all right you'll
Billy brown shirt I've vomited a little
my mouth halfway through your tirade
against fat [ __ ] when you suggest I
don't remember doing this those who
don't conform to your body dysmorphic
ideal should get therapy and sort out
their lives did I say that guys you have
to understand something like I have to
do an hour usually by myself and
whatever topic comes up I have to
destroy it because I'm trying to make
you laugh anyways I haven't heard
anything less healthy come out of your
mouth for some time alright you know
something dude first of all the I
vomited a little bit in my life the fact
that I'm supposed to literally take what
you're saying seriously and you're
speaking in sound bites
let me guess then did you shake your
head before you rolled on the floor
laughing your ass off anyways if my
partner thought my weight was a
deal-breaker I'd thank her for the
honest glimpse into her vacant prison
soul and abandoned her in a heartbeat no
you wouldn't
the overly sensitive jackass in a
heartbeat to that greyhound inspired
Instagram influencers and consumer
program Neela's you seemed a champion
diversity is not a mental illness but
body shaming is oh god yeah Wow I got a
guy got it I got it like that's that's
worded so much in that speak that I
don't even believe that that's true
no they're just throwing buzzwords
together Brown shirt all of that type of
stuff I'll oh now I see why they call
you Billy brown shirt like I'm
mad at you yeah no cuz of what it was
was there was a guy who was with some
chick she had a little meat on her bones
whatever he's in he was mine into it
thinking I should probably [ __ ] lose
eventually I don't know why I thought
that people tend to just get fatter yeah
people people do tend to age it'd be
like this guy has a little gray hair
maybe it's gonna turn brown no it's
gonna if it's gonna get more gray yes so
anyway age and if so what happens is
yeah but she was putting it on at what
he considered to be an alarming rate so
he wanted to stay with her but he needed
to know how to approach to ask her in a
polite way
disdain sure here's what you're not
least gain weight here's what all these
proud fat people are not they're killing
themselves so if somebody does an
intervention and thing about fatties is
they'll [ __ ] sit there and I'll talk
about how addiction food addiction and
all that is no different than drug
addiction I completely agree yeah but
you have an intervention with people to
be like you're killing yourself with
this heroin so I have for some reason
with Big Mac yeah you can't [ __ ] be
like hey why don't you lay off you
[ __ ] chicken tenders there so I have
a friend that that just had a kid my
buddy and he he was he lost a little bit
of weight because he had pre-diabetes
but he's putting it back on again and
like we had a thing tonight and and I
was like I was like hey man like you you
know you look like you're putting on
more weight and he goes yeah you know
it's just the stress and blah blah blah
I'm like I know but you know we're
celebrating your kid's birthday it's
just you should just you know any weight
he wants to do it it's like that by
saying that it's just that reality check
just to let him know I'm not shaming him
but I don't think he's shaming his
girlfriend either that that you know
that dude that wrote in so it's it's
just kind of like a you know it's like
you said it's health you know it's you
gotta you gotta stop you know yeah
[ __ ] just you got to be exercise if
you want to live you got to exercise to
take care of yourself what you eat is
fuel it doesn't need to be delicious
every time I'm not gonna say his name
but a guy I knew a couple years ago yeah
the last time I saw him I saw him
sitting down I go this guy does not look
good and he was not eating healthy food
and he's [ __ ] dead a month later [ __ ]
yeah dude it's just lame but you're not
supposed to say
if somebody was a day to heroin out and
I got a temper and [ __ ] my wife can skin
step in on that but there's something
about like you know being fat these
people are just like no man I'm a
[ __ ] eight
you've just been convinced by sis like
they take it like you're saying they're
not beautiful people it's like you know
if I just saw you were just some fat
[ __ ] you know I don't know it wasn't my
[ __ ] idea either man so yeah yeah you
can go [ __ ] yourself with all you stupid
like that that all all of that so you
want to about brown shirt the way this
whole thing is written this is the kind
of person that tries to make you lose
your job a million percent they're
they're very active on Yelp
yeah all right NFL titles hey pasty pig
spring pig skin professor you've asked
about Super Bowl titles versus NFL
champion said look great maybe this
person has the solution the issue here
is not the answer it's the question if
someone asks which team have never won a
Super Bowl it has a different answer
than if someone asks which team has
never won an NFL championship even a
complicated more you could ask who's
never won a league championship which
also includes AFL champion chips and
other leagues all right I understand all
of this for official NFL champions from
1920 to 1930 - there was no championship
game the championship champion was
decided by the best record only okay now
none of this is answering my question
that's like back in the day when
baseball all those World Series that
they count you know winning the pennant
was back in the year back in the day you
had the brand of the regular season if
you had the best record in the American
League you won the pennant there was no
playoff yeah and then you went to the
champions the World Series yeah so all
those years the Yankees won all those
[ __ ] titles they had one playoff
series to win it wasn't this divisional
it wasn't three rounds of playoffs which
people have to do now were they doing
but were they doing when they got to
that World Series was it how many games
was it was that was fine that was still
seven games the early 1900s where it was
best whose best five out of nine that's
five out of nine yeah [ __ ] dude that
would go into like December they did
that now like I think the Red Sox 1903
we won that World Series five games to
three hey May
man it's gay man coming to your house
for Game eight anyways 1933 to 1969
there was a championship game and the
winner of that was the NFL champion from
1966 on that champion went on to play in
the Super Bowl and the winner was called
the world champion that's not true
66 67 68 the end of those seasons or
whatever those are 66 67 68 69 whatever
it was those first three against the AFL
was called the AFL NFL title was not
called the Super Bowl
later on retro actively it was named the
Super Bowl for 1960 to 69 AFL had
champions that's true but they aren't
counted as NFL history but they are
counted as the team's history if you are
asking how many yes okay from 1966 69
the NFL AFL champions played the Super
Bowl
let's guys just telling me [ __ ] they
didn't play the Super Bowl it was
renamed that does he know should be
called facts yeah just fact facts facts
facts facts okay so in 1966 the AFL
champions the Kansas City Chip Chiefs
the NFL champions Green Bay Packers this
is the plus one League championship for
each team Chiefs lost when they played
in the first NFL if so they didn't get a
Super Bowl win but they still the AFL
champion I understand all of this I
understand all of this
none of that cleared anything up I'm
saying why don't they count those yeah
it's like you go to the stadium like the
AFL merged to be part of the NFL so
you're saying that at any most NFL
stadiums there are no trophies to
represent the league championship at the
floor I'm sure in the somewhere in the
stadium maybe they'll have they'll have
that but it's just like you know when
you go to you know you go to [ __ ] Red
Sox Fenway Park I mean we have our
banners right down the thing 1903 to
[ __ ] 2018 yeah everybody has all of
that there all of them count know that
that sir I appreciate was fun to read
all that
history but that didn't answer my
question why aren't they counted I mean
when it comes to the Super Bowl man it's
just if it's not in theirs those words
super and Bowl aren't before them they
just they act like it didn't happen act
like it didn't happen yeah well I mean
it's it's just you could still say do
championships but I got completely see
what you're saying right now it actually
kind of [ __ ] up they've never won a
Super Bowl that last thing they won was
an NFL title it's like yeah well that
was the peak of [ __ ] in 1960 they were
the best [ __ ] football team out there
and you're talking about it like it
would like they they they they lost the
election yeah I don't know
anyways living in Wyoming hey Billy said
it's a city slicker I was listening to
some older podcast episodes and came
across a rant you had about Wyoming I
like Wyoming I didn't remember what I
said like these people did bits I live
in Wyoming I got to say you are not too
far off I listened to the podcast every
week while I feel my cows off feed my
cows off the back of a flatbed truck
shut up find out of this guy's [ __ ] with
me last week we killed a problem
mountain lion and next weekend we'll be
entering into a competitive coyote hunt
I live in the absolute middle of [ __ ]
nowhere this sounds amazing this guy
this guy listens to Steve Earle yeah but
this guy is way more interesting at a
party than I am I just and up comedy oh
yeah what did you do yeah you know I
saved five of our sheep you know from a
mountain lion by I can't even turn it
off I came in third in the coyote hunt
national I want to talk to that guy the
nearest town population is 3,000 miles
and it's 40 miles away also just to
clear the air most of the billionaire
[ __ ] live up in Jackson and the rest of
my home oh that's what I'm saying I
still wanna be the douche in Hollywood
that gets a place in Wyoming and the
rest of Wyoming pretty much discounts
Jackson as being part of the state
anyway so pretty much discount status
being part of state partially unrelated
I finished getting my pilot's license
last year and hope to start on my
helicopter rating within the next year
good for you my family has used a Bell
Jet Ranger
coyotes Jesus how much more of an
advantage do you need for three
generations that are flying the heli do
you have like one of those [ __ ] how
do you shoot a doe easy you just don't
lead him as much am i ready to start
flying the heli to carry on the oh and
I'm ready to start flying I had to carry
on the tradition so cheers to a fellow
pilot that's cool as [ __ ] I just wanted
to let you know there's at least one
[ __ ] listening to your podcast in
Wyoming and love all the [ __ ] you put
out thanks and go [ __ ] yourself that's
cool man I'm trying to get eight hours a
month flying have you been flying a lot
recently I got seven point nine for this
month and I'm fine tomorrow morning good
and what are you gonna take me up dude
when I have throw over 300 hours and I'm
gonna do a little bit of instrument
training and just get better at it and
and like do some full I would do full
downs and the whole [ __ ] thing before
I would ever take out my first passenger
and I love you too much to have you be
my first passenger but there's a few
people in my life that I like so I'll be
taking them up first okay I believe it
and then and you know what I mean it's
just like do I want to kill this guy or
this guy wait dude was like Sophie's
Choice with a helicopter
are we gonna go we're gonna go to see
Iron Maiden in Las Vegas and then that
should be like the time that we do that
yes if you want to try a new cigar check
out Deadwood tobacco company out of
Deadwood South Dakota the sweet Jane is
is my favorite cigar I have ever smoked
see you you see your bald [ __ ] well I
mean some guy out there and the [ __ ]
range shootin coyotes I bet I know what
a Deadwood yeah that sounds [ __ ]
pretty cool to me all right let me go
wrap this thing up do we get some our
three minutes perfect all right drone yo
Billy up there you were talking about a
drone last week that would taxi people
around sounded like the one you
mentioned was unmanned check this thing
out 57 batteries yeah dude that is I was
joking about that [ __ ] thing - they
gonna do this thing rather than deal
with the population problem the next
thing I do is have like like like a
looks like it looks like a helicopter
and you just get in it there's nobody in
there
and it'll just like take you across LA
now first of all I would think would be
super expensive unless it's electric and
listen yeah
Elon Musk can make the thing but dude
you know your [ __ ] laptop crashes
your phone craps out on you I feel good
like dude you're gonna fly somebody like
over a like the level of insurance like
how you gonna do that
I was joking that you're gonna have some
hipster come fly through on his way to a
pocketwatch convention out and [ __ ]
Venice Beach or something all we found
was his handlebar mustache yeah he was
on his way to this to meet this food
truck yeah whatever I think it's been so
there there's a so what I just wanna get
this paper okay show you something super
please show it to me boy I'm just trying
to cuz I'm not gonna confuse your saying
there is going to be a transportation
that like it's a drone so it's like you
get into a tube and then it just lifts
the tube up and flies you kind of looks
like a helicopter it looks [ __ ] cool
as [ __ ] I think it looks [ __ ] cool
you showing us how are you showing me
now no I want to show you this this app
here for flight and this is what I'm
getting better right here so this this
here once I I get good at you know
confident enough in my abilities and I
take up a passenger so it just you don't
have to know it's not like back in the
[ __ ] day we had to have like a
[ __ ] sectional map on your in your
honor if I can thigh is you're flying
around this thing gives you all the the
airports all the you know Santa Barbara
where we were the this van nuys there's
Burbank right there so it's pink so
that's a Charlie and then you go what's
so great is you can just [ __ ] type in
whatever you want to type in it gives
you the ATIS it gives you the contact
tower it has a map runway hey this is
probably most time with you land out
there and why they slam on the brakes
because this is so [ __ ] short that is
a small ass landing strip yeah well I
don't know how you can tell it from the
app I think because I just told you it
was being a [ __ ] right now there's El
flat Burbank
there's El Monte that's one of my
favorite ones
but it has all but it has si would you
see what this is so boring for people
here but you see right there that's a
delta so grounded 2400 right here when
you're flying along the the 215 you know
I'm gonna be in the airspace I gotta
call them and they'll just give you
clearance all the way through and then
once you learn how to read this [ __ ]
think you can kind of just fly around
out here now the rest of the country
they actually have to deal with weather
see I don't have to do because people
like you should fly across the country
it's like ah this is a dry climate that
I don't have to ever deal with hey
everything's beauty el and then all of a
sudden you know I can't see anything
there's a brutal [ __ ] call of a guy
who like me is not instrument-rated yeah
which means if the clouds came in
underneath me I don't know how to get
back down other than to just shut my
eyes and go through the clouds and hope
yeah yeah so he's up there and the soup
is or whatever the [ __ ] they call it and
dude this guy is free but the guy talked
him down and then afterwards he [ __ ]
so he lived yeah but he called the tower
he goes uh yeah thanks about and the guy
says total ice snow yeah we goes what
happened up there
yeah you [ __ ] [ __ ] he's basically
you're saying what happened up there is
he got involved in some [ __ ] that that
you know he wasn't even four so that's
that's the one weird thing about flying
as you learned by other people died he
[Music]
won one time who this guy was doing a
tour in the 44 Robinson 44 and he had
three people there when he took off
right yeah [ __ ] just did this really
just I don't know what he just didn't go
like he just ignored everything he's
supposed to do he was loaded up with
people he had I imagine you know heavy
with fuel so what you want to do is you
should forward momentum to get going he
just pulled all this [ __ ] power and
his low rpm horn comes on yeah now the
weird thing was the chicken the
passengers she was going well like right
at this is like the same [ __ ] note so
he didn't hear it at first and all he
had to do he was Bank come out of the
bank lower your collective and it'll go
off and then just gradually climb up and
he did it for a second and then he
pulled it again and it came on again and
then he
just started descending and you your
instinct is you want a polka you want to
go up ya actually want to you actually
want to bring you collective down he
kept pulling power and he's [ __ ] her
in the ground they all [ __ ] died oh
[ __ ] man yeah so I'll take you up all
right girlfriend is pregnant hey Billy
sad tits
I mean I'm 28 years old and my 26 year
old girlfriend just found out she's
pregnant now you're saying this dude
like you didn't blow the load in her she
found out she's pregnant like she got
[ __ ] shingles or something this came
as a big shock because I previously had
a vasectomy when I was 22 ah this isn't
Jesus Christ at 22 you they had nine
kids by then are you never wanted any
heat of a second 22 said I never had
never wanted kids after she told me I
went to urologist who told me I had
regained a sperm count although rare it
was not unheard of when I met this girl
she changed my life I had never trusted
or loved any woman the way I do her
she's the light of my life but weren't
planning on this we both have okay jobs
but living in California is expensive
and adding a third mouth to feed and
paying for doctor's visits will crush us
financially
she doesn't have health insurance do you
have any advice for me my fear is losing
the chance to have kids with her as this
may be a miracle considering my
vasectomy and considered you waited a
long time to have kids I want to know if
you think this would be good for someone
in my position to go through this thanks
for taking time to read this poorly and
probably not understand my situation you
old gray [ __ ] the old gray Conte ain't
what he used to be love your shows and I
hope you hear I hope to hear more your
ramblings from you best to you the baby
and go [ __ ] yourself and your gay ass
Patriots alright um okay can I take this
because I think that he should do it
yeah I think you don't well don't wait
on life for your financial situation man
if if you guys will make it work that's
what you will make it work you'll figure
it out you might not think that you have
enough money right now but something
like life is constantly changing and
evolving and it's just like lay off the
microbe ruse and have the kid
exactly like you'll make it work just I
think you should you should consider it
a miracle just like you said I think
it's a great thing I'm actually really
happy for you and I think put it this
way I wish you know I wish I didn't wait
as long as I did and the other day I was
watching this I was watching this this
kids song it's just as simple that it's
like snowflake snowflake little
snowflake snowflake snowflake da da duh
and my daughter was trying to sing it
and she was throwing a head back cause I
think wasn't quite fit
dude I I got had to fight off getting
emotional just watching her do that is
the most beautiful thing in the world
and there's nothing
up until then anything [ __ ] done
Madison Square Garden was not as good as
that naughty and not even remotely
it's like Madison Stroger I was like wow
that's amazing
but that moment with my daughter was
like this is what life is all about a
hundred percent this is yeah it's all
about and then another great thing is
you become a dad and one of the greatest
[ __ ] things ever and some sage advice
I learned from a good dad is he said I
watched him is because he goes it's not
about you anymore and at first I kind of
took that as like you know because I'm
not buried like like don't tell me what
the [ __ ] to do idiot sometimes
and then I realized how great that is
like the other day I finally had a day
off and my wife wanted to go on go get
some breakfast because you want to do
that was like now finally home I want to
stay home so that was just like I [ __ ]
it that's what she wants to do and we
just went out that I said yeah it's not
about you they want to go out to
breakfast take them out to [ __ ]
breakfast and I went out to breakfast
but I had a great [ __ ] time and I had
great time and it's weird when you're
home you're a dad or whatever blah blah
but when you go out you kind of feel
more like a dad no it's like you take us
out to dinner come out of the car you
walk and she's holding your hand or
you're carrying her you go in you get
her in the little booster seat you get
her whatever like it's usually like a
mac and cheese or like a cut-up hot dog
or some [ __ ] I assume that she's at that
age and you did you just people are
looking at the kid look how beautiful
the kid is again
I know it's like dude you're in your
element man yeah no it's awesome you
know what's cool is she's really really
beginning to talk now yeah so yeah it's
getting the point where I can actually
convey to her and she will understand
how much I love her which is gonna be
great
yeah cuz that we say you guys watch I
love you do you understand that and
should just be looking at you smiling
whatever but now I'll actually be able
to say it she'll be able to understand
it yeah I can't wait can't wait to
[ __ ] play catch with her I want to
teach how to drive my truck three in the
tree
yeah what what kid born in 2018 is gonna
know that it works 27 sorry no no I did
forget about drivers stick five three on
the column okay today I took it over to
Jiffy Lube which I know a lot of [ __ ]
car people gonna give me [ __ ] for that
you want to Jiffy Lube well I would
change it but the the way they design
them the guy who ever [ __ ] designed
the engine did not talk to the guy who
[ __ ] design the frame on that truck
because the frame there's like literally
a piece that goes from one side of the
other right underneath the [ __ ] plug
for the drain playing pin so the only
one it's just a giant [ __ ] mess like
when they do it they have to have this
giant thing underneath it and it comes
down and splashes all over that that
piece that goes across and then they
have like this spray thing and then the
air thing that they shoot all off it's
like I'm gonna do that my garage and
have a [ __ ] oil spill I can't do it I
hate it I gotta take it in I used to
love doing it when I was a kid I used to
that was like my favorite thing cuz I
knew how to do it I would change the
fuel filter I knew how to do a lube job
and he'll do the whole [ __ ] all of
that maintenance stuff but I never had
the balls to start taking apart the
[ __ ] engine or whatever but anyways
that's the podcast we got a cigar to
smoke
hey you'll pick the Super Bowl Patriots
Rams I think it's gonna be the Patriots
I really do so I do I'm going to be
honest with you like I I kind of I love
watching greatness and I know what
people like to hate on the Patriots and
I know I tease you sometimes but it's
just like dude he's so good the team is
so good man and it's like to be able to
say that I watched Michael Jordan win
six like I know I was alive during that
and nobody else has matched that
greatness except for Tom Brady well I
think it's gonna I'm gonna die a
thousand deaths as always and I really
think that I mean we're going up
against what's looking like the next
Belichick McVeigh late [ __ ] 33 34
years old I mean it's [ __ ] ridiculous
he was a skin dude he was our offensive
coordinator like and we gave him up like
he we have [ __ ] one of the goddamn
Gruden's you ain't doing [ __ ] I know
Belichick coached the Browns at one
point and it happens dude it happens all
right
that's the podcast I'm hoping my
Patriots win I have no idea what's gonna
happen the [ __ ] Rams look great and I
think their quarterback like they just
don't make quarterbacks the way they
used to like they don't come into the
league scared they just [ __ ] come in
like I whatever I don't know what it is
maybe because they video games and [ __ ]
they've already seen saying I'm it but
that guy used to beat them all the time
in eighth grade now I'm playing them now
he's [ __ ] older I'm not scared of any
of these people
alright I'm rambling can I give my final
pitch on the podcast yes guys everybody
my podcasts called the 500 with Josh out
of Meijer join the record book club
we're going through the 500 greatest
albums of all time
Bill's done it Jim Jefferies we got just
table Wanda Sykes do an Earth Wind and
Fire it's cool it's my [ __ ] favorite
thing I've ever done experienced the
greatest music of all time and then hear
me and I did a comic talk [ __ ] about it
not shed a great just listen to it check
it out Josh Adam Meyers the 500 all
right I'll see you on Thursday